et la situation est bien plus stable
autour de la capitale autour de kiev
même si les bâtiments là bas aussi sont
détruits on retrouve notre envoyé
spécial cyril payen à erbine bonjour
cyril vous voilà de retour dans ses
anciennes zones de guerre vous étiez sur
place pour france 24 il y a deux mois en
plein dans les combats qu'est ce qui a
changé
bah écoutez nous sommes sur la avec avec
bora bora sur les hauteurs cette petite
colline de la ville d'hier pin je
rappelle cette zone résidentielle avec
bocsa et au sto mail dont on a beaucoup
parlé effectivement quand il y avait cet
énorme poussée militaire russe et voilà
la conséquence ce cimetière civil dans
le dans lequel nous sommes nous dominons
la ville d'hier pin kiev et à 15 km dans
cette direction il y a plusieurs
centaines de tombes des tombes
fraîchement
refermer ce sont essentiellement des
civils qui ont été tués pendant ces
combats intenses nous venons de passer
quelques heures effectivement dans cet
endroit qui porte encore résolument les
stigmates de cette énorme offensive pour
tenter de prendre en vain on le sait
maintenant la capitale que kiev mais
effectivement on voit des normes des
normes stigmates de ces de ses combats
nous avons passé une heure dans un
village qui a été à 95% détruit aucun
habitant n'a survécu il ya des tanks
russes un peu partout mais on sent bien
qu au delà de ces images glaçantes
terrible tous ces immeubles qui sont
autour de nous complètement ou
partiellement détruits mais dont on sait
qu'il faudra beaucoup d'années pour
reprendre une vie normale il ya une
formidable volonté de résilience et
c'est d'ailleurs ce que nous disait il
ya quelques instants une équipe de la
gendarmerie scientifique française
puisque oui les français sur la une
vingtaine de gendarmes à pied d'oeuvre
avec le gros du procureur international
pour justement tenter de fixer
d'apporter des preuves des crimes de
guerre puisque c'est le grand sujet du
moment ce procès qui a commencé il y a
quelques jours à actifs pour fixer donc
toutes ces questions de crimes de guerre
qui ont été perpétrés notamment ici même
dans la région de boudhha au sto mail ou
ir pin qui ont des endroits qui ont été
partiellement ou complètement détruite
où les morts se comptent par centaines
sinon par par milliers
derrière vous et par votre témoignage
cheryl
ces bombardements le passage des russes
a laissé beaucoup de traces autour de
kiev comment est ce que les ukrainiens
du coup font-ils pour se relever
écoutez c'est ce qui est très frappant
puisque nous avons traversé depuis
l'ouest la l'ukraine hier depuis 24
heures pour rejoindre kiev il y a
évidemment la difficulté de la vie une
influence d'inflation galopante plus de
20% tout est extrêmement cher on voit et
ça ça devient un phénomène familier des
centaines de voitures qui font la queue
tous les jours pour avoir 20 litres
d'essence il n'y a plus d'essence dans
le pays depuis que l'art thierry russe a
détruit les grands stocks de les grands
stocks de réserve d'essence mais à part
ça encore une fois cette ville kiev que
nous avons retrouvée qui était sous loi
martiale il y à deux mois avec un couvre
feu extrêmement strict qui à partir de 7
heures on pouvait plus sortir le soir
rien et est ouvert eh bien là c'est une
ville transfigurée presque vibrante je
dirais qui fait qui marqua c'est ce
paradoxe entre ce qui peut être encore
7,7 ce pays qui est encore en guerre
avec les courbes à vous le disiez qui
font rage à marioupol dans l'est dans le
donbass temps en crimée et puis qui
sommes a donc là quelques centaines des
kilomètres de là où se trouve et c'est
énorme volonté résiliente d'une partie
de la population ukrainienne qui tente
de revivre à tout prix de relancer les
affaires d'ouvrir les magasins de
réparer les maisons donc outre ce
spectacle désolant il faut le dire de
ces centaines de civils qui est bien sûr
les collatéral les victimes collatérales
de ce conflit de cette invasion rouge
pour être trois mois après le début de
la guerre et bien c'est aussi c'est
extraordinaire volonté de passer outre
et de seuil et de revivre malgré tout
dans ses envois merci beaucoup
cyril payen pour votre témoignage et
merci également à la personne qui est
derrière la caméra j'ai oublié le nom
envoyé spécial donc france 24 à abuja
dans le cimetière